there's the scene in Goodfellas where
your mother plays Joe Pesci's mother and
she's making food for him Robert De Niro
and Ray Liotta and it's so naturalistic
yeah the thing is that I grew up the
Italian-American neighbor you know there
was organized crime and some family
members just gone off the wrong way and
and that doesn't mean the mothers didn't
love the sons the same way and so she
doesn't care what her son does he's home
three o'clock in the morning let me give
you some food Where Have You Been for
three nights you know all your friends
come on in come on in don't worry eat
something you're not concerned that they
just beat some guys I didn't tell her I
might didn't tell my mother there was a
body in the trunk I just said your son
is home cooked some food Bob is playing
an Irish guy give him some potatoes that
kind of stuff that was a whole thing and
then they improvised everything the only
thing that was written was did you see
my painting and everything else was
improvised with my mother saying why
don't you settle down he said do I do I
wonder if you get a nice girl and settle
down Joe says you know I do I get a nice
girl every night I settle down
I love you Mom and that all of that went
on with two cameras and I just sat there
two cameras and a small little house in
Astoria I think in Queens but no it's a
very special thing but she does love her
son unequivocally